thanks hi in this clock i'll talk about
a line of work on minimax optimal policy
learning under unobserved confounding so
observational causal inference and in a
single time step setting um and this is
part of a kind of broader line of work
on developing methodological toolkits
that uh interpolate between causal
inference under making wrong assumptions
versus not conducting machine learning
altogether
um and so let me speak informally for a
few minutes about some of the central
challenges of causal inference
and this will be in the single time step
setting before i uh highlight this
important challenge of unobserved
confounding that this work is going to
focus on
um and so we're interested in this
offline batch learning from bandit
feedback as it's sometimes called
setting again in a single time step
setting so imagine we have a large
observational database for example
medical records and it contains
individual level records of covariates x
the actions that were historically taken
and of course uh the outcomes but only
for the actions that were historically
taken and so again in this offline
setting the key challenge is that we
don't have the capacity to run online
experimentation we want to best
statistically estimate or impute the
value of alternative actions in view of
the statistical correlation between
treatments and outcomes that arises in
the data set so that is the kind of
classical challenge of causal inference
and so i want to
position this kind of modern problem in
the middle against two benchmarks that
can kind of help illustrate the
challenges so on the one hand
traditional cultural inference on the
left
is
has been primarily focused on making
good decisions based on so-called
average treatment effects so traditional
clinical trials obtain really sharp uh
statistical estimation of the treatment
effect of assigning treatment to
everyone or no one in turn this informs
the optimal decision for either treating
everyone or no one
but we may be interested in more
covariant conditional decisions such as
the case in personalized medicine or
reinforcement learning in the more
advanced versions of this and so on um
and so on the other hand for these kinds
of um covariate rich problems the best
case scenario is if in our observational
data set we actually recorded the
outcome under the treatment for everyone
and if we actually knew which one was
better then of course this vision of
making covariate conditional decisions
is simply just normal machine learning
classification so the central challenge
is simply that we have these
observational data sets with missing
outcomes and we want to statistically
impute these outcomes
accounting for the statistical
correlations between
actions historically observed and the
outcomes that we observe and so
those are the key challenges in causal
inference i'm going to focus on the case
of unobserved confounders so there could
be additional information
that is correlated with the historical
actions and is also correlated with the
outcomes but is not actually observed in
our data sets so it's a very common
practical challenge this is assumed away
by the whole statistical framework of
causal inference for the most part
except for some other variations
and i'm going to focus on
translating uh translating this
personalized problem into robust machine
learning
um so just to recap we have this single
time step data set with covariates
actions and outcomes
most work assumes this unconfoundingness
assumption that
potential outcomes are conditionally
independent of the treatment assignment
conditional on a set of coverts that i
measure and so the the promise is that
if i measure more information i would be
better able to adjust for
patterns in the treatment assignment
and so just to highlight uh some of the
aspects in the policy learning setting
what is my new
kind of
performance metric is simply the
population expectation of the outcomes
that are induced if i assign treatments
according to this policy um and in this
robust framework we're going to think
about regret against the baseline but
that's not so crucial for the
for the environment
but the key idea is that all of these
metrics for assessing benchmarks for
assessing policy value now have to be
statistically estimated in the causal
setting and we're going to
estimate these robustly under moderate
violations of unconfoundedness
and so let me just describe the kind of
general recipe for
uh robust machine learning in this type
of framework and so we're going to start
with the estimator or the estimator from
causal inference and identify the part
of the estimator that depends on the
unknown structure or the unobserved
confounding and so actually classical
results in causal inference allow us to
identify that it only depends on the
so-called propensity score or the
probability of treatment assignment
given both the known and unknown
quantities
and so secondly
we parameterize the
allowable extent of unobserved
confounding via some kind of sensitivity
model so here we are building on causal
inference which has of course studied
sensitivity analysis for just the
training bounds on average human effects
but maybe not these personalized effects
and so now in this setting
the recipe looks quite like modern
robust machine learning given this
uncertainty set or sensitivity model we
want to both evaluate worst-case
estimates of the of some policy but we
ultimately want to find some policy or
some classifier which provides
guarantees
to achieve the best worst case regret
so the the key challenge in the setting
is is mostly establishing statistical
performance in the setting with
ambiguity where
the size of these sensitivity models
does not actually vanish in the limit as
we collect more data we don't because we
don't
we don't we aren't able to calibrate the
size of these assumptions from the
observed observational data
okay so just to be more concrete we're
going to robustify a very classical set
of estimators from causal inference
based on inverse propensity reading
and we're going to solve this kind of
robust erm problem
and let me briefly describe the kinds of
guarantees that we can provide about
this type of procedure and so
broadly the the guarantees split into
decision theoretic guarantees
these hold by design of the optimization
or the robust optimization which allows
us to say something about our out of
sample improvement over a baseline so
long as we well specify the uncertainty
set and the other kind of guarantee is
more statistical because it's just about
re-establishing the
rate of convergence
once we've devised this kind of custom
optimization framework and it's not
obvious from the start just because we
allow the optimization to vary for every
data point and then the limit this can
vary arbitrarily
and so
this is just about interleaving from the
generalization analysis and some of the
specific optimization structure of these
estimators
so
i won't go into details but
there are there's a nice case study with
a pair of observational studying
clinical trial and so this is really
about interpolating um between making
assumptions and
being completely agnostic
okay so i'll just
skip to
some
current directions of interest so i
think uh working with these custom
estimators highlights opportunities to
just sharpen our understanding of
optimization problems under uncertainty
as well as these optimized estimation
problems will react just based on
organization statistics
as well as other opportunities for
causal influence and more complex
systems
so one quick question uh while adil
shares his screen for the next talk
would you say that there's ambiguity
[Music]
yeah yeah so the ambiguity arises
because the data is observational and
the absorb observed joint distribution
is uninformative about
the unobserved confounding so one can't
run any statistical tests or so on to
become data
thank you
[Music]
you